new at 11 tonight a dog found nearly
starving to death in a junkyard just a
few months though after he was fostered
from the animal foundation now as he
starts his recovery a las vegas rescue
group wants answers as to how this could
have happened to a dog that was supposed
to go to his forever home victoria saha
has our story
twelve-year-old anakin is just starting
to gain back some strength he felt
defeated because he felt the world
forgot about him you could just almost
see that in his demeanor this is how
anakin looked right before he was
fostered out of the animal foundation in
october
and this is how he was found just last
week in a junkyard this pitbull mix was
so hungry he kept eating rocks to
survive which also destroyed his teeth
he is a senior dog so for him to be in
this condition is just
it's unthinkable that somebody would
allow this to happen you can see just
how malnourished anakin is his rib cage
is popping out and his caretakers here
at the vet say he must have been
starving for at least a few weeks for
that to happen but the good news is he's
already gained about a pound since being
here for a few days but the question is
how did anakin get to this horrific
state the animal foundation says he was
part of an open foster to adoption
process where there are no background
checks and no fees anakin was found not
neutered which is unheard of for
shelters the animal foundation says his
adoption would have been finalized after
his neuter surgery somebody just missed
this file somebody just missed this dog
being neutered being taken care of by
his foster as for now anakin is taking
one paw at a time on his road to
recovery at spencer springs animal
hospital victoria saha live local now